uh i'm very happy to have uh francesca
molinare from the economics department
at cornell university
uh francesca has done a lot of important
work both in theoretical and applied
econometrics and today she'll be talking
to us about identification analysis with
uh set value predictions
thank you so much francesca and uh yeah
the floor is yours
thank you thank you so much for uh
including this work in this uh very
interesting conference
i should say that what i'm gonna talk
about is in part based on work that i've
done a while ago with uh ilia molchanov
and daria barciano
and
the reasoning to talk to you about
things that we've published a while ago
is that there is a lot of scope i think
for um
benefiting from this community and so i
want to talk to you about what are the
problems that economists think about
within this class of models and what are
open questions where i'm pretty sure
that we would benefit from input from
this group
so first i just want to very quickly
um
get on with the same language in terms
of what what do we mean by
identification analysis
and this actually is i think a good
segue to the previous presentation
so what we want to do here is to learn
features of the relationship between
some variables y x and epsilon and to
make it concrete and
in light of the example that i'm going
to use as my working example throughout
think of the y the outcome variable as a
vector of players actions enter the
market don't enter the market
think of x as a vector of payoff
shifters which have the property that
the econometrician researcher can
observe this payoff shifters
and think of epsilon as a vector of not
observable payoff shifters usually
economists think about fixed costs or
other features of the cost function of
firms that
the researcher cannot observe all firms
observe this
features excellent but the researcher
does not
and what we want to do is to learn the
payoff function and in particular often
the interest of the researcher is into
is in learning the interaction effect so
what's the effect
on the
profits on the payoffs of player one
due to the presence or absence in the
market of player two okay
what do we observe as researcher the
only thing that we observe
is data on y and x the outcomes of the
game and observable payoff shifters and
from observing this data we can learn
their joint distribution p0
what we're going to do is to posit
restrictions on the data generating
process
from which which has determined y x and
epsilon and again to go back to my entry
game example
for example i'm going to assume that the
observed outcome of the game results
from static simultaneous movement play
that's a restriction on behavior i'm
going to assume that i know the
functional form of the payoffs
of the players so that this is a
function which i know up to some finite
dimensional vector theta one and i'm
going to assume that the distribution
of the unobservable payoff shifters is
also known up to some other vector theta
two okay
and what i want to do is to learn theta
one and theta two
and f and possibly feature of the joint
distribution of the observables
i'm gonna denote by capital theta the
parameter space where the parameter
vector theta lies and by theta zero
the true data generating value that's
the thing i want to learn as a
researcher
i'm gonna assume throughout
for most of this talk that my model is
correctly specified so that all these
assumptions that i'm making about
behavior and so on are correct
and then what i want to do the key
question of identification analysis is
what can be learned about data from the
observed data and the maintained
assumptions
okay
now historically uh and most
traditionally identification analysis
has always has focused on what i'm going
to refer to as complete models and what
are complete models these are models
where given a value of x epsilon and
theta the model tells you uniquely
what's the value of the outcome
okay
and and i i will give i will come back
to an example to to
make this concrete when i
go to my entry game example
and so in models which are complete
because for a given value of y x and
epsilon there is a uniquely predicted
value for the outcomes
as an implication of this i'm also going
to have
a unique model implied distribution of y
and x
associated with each possible value of
theta in the parameter space okay
and we say that the model is point
identified so that the parameters theta
can be recovered if you wish from the
observation of the joint distribution of
y and x
if
whenever i take a value of theta which
is different from the true data
generating value theta 0
the distribution
of y and x
implied by the model when i plug this
candidate value theta into the model
is different from the distribution of y
and x implied by the model when i plug
the true data generated in value theta 0
and of course if the model is correctly
specified
the distribution
of the data implied under theta 0 by the
model is equal to the distribution of y
and x that i see in the data
okay
so now
how am i going to deviate in this talk
from these basic ideas is that more
recently and more specifically in
connection with the topic of this
conference
identification analysis has been
studying models which are incomplete
meaning these are models where when you
give me a value of the observable payoff
shifters and observable payoff shifters
and the parameter vector theta
the model returns to me a set of values
for the outcome variable of interest
the example that we're going to look at
is an example of a two-player entry
regain
and the reason why i'm going to get the
value a set of values for the outcome
variable is because this class of models
has
multiple equilibria and the multiple
equilibria gave me the
the multiplicity of prediction for the
outcome of the game
because there are multiple outcomes of
the game that are predicted
there are as a consequence also multiple
distributions for y and x
for the giant distribution of y and x
given by the model okay
and so in this case we cannot obtain
point identification of
the true value theta 0 but we can still
learn something quite useful about theta
0 which is a set of observational
equivalent parameter vectors that set of
observational equivalent parameter
vectors is what i'm going to refer to as
the sharp identification region for
theta 0 which i'm going to denote by
capital theta with a subscript i to
indicate that this is what can be
learned about theta in this course of
models and what is going to be
this set this set is going to be
comprised of parameters theta such that
when you plug them into the model
you obtain a joint distribution for y
and x which matches the one that you
observe in the data
if you quickly compare with the
definition of point identification
the difference here the definition is
based on the same idea of equating
p of y comma x
under theta with the p zero y comma x
except that in the case of point
identification the set gita is a
singleton
but when you have models which are
incomplete the set the certified
is uh generically not going to be a
single tool
and so then the goals of uh partial
identification analysis are
to provide computational tractable
characterization for this set of
observational equivalent parameter
vectors and to provide tools for
statistical inference on this set of
parameter vectors
i will attempt to draw a connection with
the previous talk
if you think about what was discussed in
the previous talk when the index of
whichever was the profession that gives
the highest
wages and therefore is selected is not
observed the previous talk concluded by
saying that well i think identifiability
may not be possible
so the standard point identification
literature would say okay let me think
really hard and try to find a sufficient
set of restrictions on the model that
will still allow me to say that there is
a unique value that is zero and it will
allow you it will allow me to uniquely
pin down this value theta zero
the problem that we try to face here is
that sometimes this additional
restriction that we need to impose to
shrink this set data i could be a single
term are assumptions that are
non-testable there are assumptions which
don't come from
the underlying theory behind the model
or from in in our case from economic
theory and so we want to avoid these
assumptions altogether
and so we want to say okay if i don't if
i cannot make credible assumptions or
assumptions that are testable
can i still learn something useful about
the parameter vector theta
and the answer is typically yes and
how can i characterize in a way that is
computationally tractable this set of
observational equivalent parameters and
once i have a characterization how can i
actually
uh put put confidence intervals test
hypothesis and so on in this context
and what i would say is that i think we
have come down with a
pretty good computationally tractable
characterization of theta i in the sense
of being able to
um
say whether a specific
we can easily say whether a specific
theta belongs to theta i
by solving a convex program as i will
show you in this in this talk
but the question of how to trace out the
entire set theta i in a computationally
good way is a completely open well not
there are some proposals in the
literature but one is fully satisfactory
of how to fully trace out this set in
cases when this step is not convex okay
so this is one of the open questions
here
okay
so before i jump into the details let me
try to give you a list non-exhaustive
list of examples
with which i would like to
argue to you that models will set value
predictions are actually quite common
so the first model that i have here on
my list is the entry game with multiple
equilibria that's the one i'm going to
focus in this talk 100
but network formation models also belong
to
the set of the the collection of models
which are set valid predictions and so
do certain type of options and this is
and this first three
are models where you have
interaction between agents and then
there is a very very long list of single
agent models where also satellite
predictions rise
okay so what i'm going to do here is to
talk to you about the two player entry
game
and first i'm going to explain why there
is an identification problem and then
i'm going to talk about partial
identification
when we allow for mixed strategy
equilibria and some easier partial
identification when we restrict to pure
strategy equilibria only
and if by any chance i have time i'm
also going to talk to you
about how to carry out statistical
inference in this class of models
based on a new working progress that
i'm doing with um only get bu hirokaido
and and otherwise if if i'm running out
of time i will have to skip this and
then i'm going to conclude
okay
so
um by the way feel free to ask questions
if anything is unclear it's a bit uh
it's a little bit extra challenging to
talk to an audience because i cannot see
anybody's face naturally
i just see the big room
but please feel free to interrupt me
so the working example that i'm going to
use here is that the simple two-player
entry game
where
each player makes zero profit
has a zero payoff if they stay out of
the market
they make monopolist pay they they make
monopolies profits if they enter a loan
and they make duopolis profits if they
enter together with their opponent where
this delta 1 and alpha 2 parameters
are the interaction of facts and they're
assumed to be negative so duopolis
profits as opposed to monopolist profits
the distribution of epsilon which i'm
going to denote by f here is going to be
assumed to be known up to parameter
uh parameter vector rho so in this case
it's just a scalar which is the
correlation between national one and
epsilon
the researcher wants to learn
uh
the vector of payoff parameters beta one
beta two delta one delta two and the
correlation between the errors so for
example the correlation between the
fixed costs of the two
players
and what the researcher observes is the
vector of observable payoffs and the
vector of realized equilibrium outcomes
of the game
now
the way that this equilibrium outcomes
of the game connect to the model is that
if we assume pure strategies only
then these realized outcomes are
elements of the set of equilibrium
and if instead we allow for mixed
strategies than the realized outcomes
are just a random mix and draw from one
of the equilibrium strategy profiles
so in terms of notation i'm going to
denote by sigma j the probability that
player j enters the market
and i'm going to abuse notation a little
bit and use the same notation
fracture u
to denote the expected payoff associated
with strategy sigma
in terms of behavioral behavioral
restrictions my key assumptions are
going to be that the observed outcome of
the game results from static
simultaneous move nash play
and that players have complete
information
i can drop complete information and make
this incomplete information
problem i'll talk a little bit about
different solution concepts later
and then i'm going to assume that the
observable data identifies the joint
distribution of y1 y2 x1 x2 for example
this would be the case
if i observe players
play the same game across markets think
about airlines
think
think about airlines deciding whether to
enter a market or not
and define a market as a city pair then
i observe
airlines decisions to enter different
markets across let's say the united
states and from seeing these airline
decisions across the united states i can
identify and eventually estimate the
joint distribution of the decisions and
of the observable payoff shifters
and f here as i said before is the joint
distribution of the
an observable pair of shifters think of
those as fixed cost and i'm going to
assume that this distribution is
continuous and known up to
the correlation parameter rule
and i'm going to rely on next strategy
nash equilibrium solution concept and
but as i will discuss later
all that follows generalizes to most or
perhaps all solution concepts i put all
here with a question mark because i'm
always concerned that maybe there is
some solution concept that i don't know
about
i will later after i put down some more
notation i will tell you what are the
crucial ingredients that the solution
concept has to satisfy for all of this
material that i'm going to show you to
apply
so
from the perspective of an
econometrician how should we think about
how does one represent
the mixed strategy nash equilibria here
on this graph
i'm putting the fixed costs that the
econometrician does not observe on the
axis here and what's going to happen is
that depending on the realization of the
fixed costs
relative
relative to
the observable up to theta part of the
payoff shifters which is the
x1 beta1 x2 beta2 and the deltas
relative to that
if the epsilons realize sufficiently
high
then
this
so up here then this model is going to
have a unique mixed strategy nash
equilibrium which is degenerate and both
players enter with probability one
if the epsilons realize sufficiently low
down here
then
there is also going to be a unique
equilibrium where both players enter
with probability zero
in the dotted region player one enters
with probability zero player two enters
the probability one the opposite in the
uh
vertical line region and the essence of
the problem and the essence of the
fact that we have set valued predictions
here occurs in the center where in the
center what happens is that we have
three mixed strategy equilibrium two are
again degenerate and one is a totally
mixed equilibrium
so because the model predicts multiple
mixed strategy nash equilibria then the
model also
has a set of potential outcomes
again in the region of multiple of uh in
regions where there is a unique
equilibrium the predicted outcome is
unique for example up here
there is a unique predicted outcome
where both players enter
but in the region of multiplicity all
four outcomes of the game are possible
so we can have that no player enter both
players enter or only one of the two
players enter so in this this is the
sense in which the model has such valued
predictions
and any solution concept for which which
is going to deliver
um
a correspondence a set of equilibria
that satisfies a certain measurability
property that i'm going to show you
later is going to be a solution concept
with which i can apply all of the all of
the results in in this talk
okay so now what i want to do next is to
formalize the notion of modeling
completeness
and then move on to explain why there is
an identification problem
so first i'm just here going to write
the standard definition of the set of
mixed strategy nash equilibria so it's
going to be the collection of strategies
so that
each player plays the best response
in our working example
this set of mixed strategy nash
equilibria is going to have either one
or three elements
when epsilon realizes such that there
are framing stratogenes equilibria then
the model is incomplete why is the model
incomplete
because we don't know how the
equilibrium that we observed played in
the market has been picked so we only
observe outcomes of the game and we
don't know whether those outcomes of the
game result from the totally mixed
equilibrium
or from the
pure strategy equilibrium
okay
so what is the way what is missing from
the model
for us to have the standard complete
model which has been in the past studied
in the econometrics literature what is
missing is a selection mechanism a rule
that would tell us
how to pick an equilibrium with to be
played in the multiplicity region
and so
uh in general a selection mechanism
would need to satisfy two key
restrictions
it has to assign a non-negative
probability
to each
of the mixed strategies which are
equilibrium
and it has to sum up to one
the problem that we face
is that this mix this selection
mechanism is completely unknown and may
depend on both x and epsilon
and what this selection mechanism does
in practice is that it builds all
possible mixtures of model predictions
so let me go back to my picture here for
a moment and before i talk about all
what's written in other parts of this
slide let me focus here and let me try
to first give you an intuition
for why we have an identification
problem here
imagine that you are
imagine that you face this problem and
you observe outcomes of the game and
your first instinct is that you will go
and you will estimate the parameters of
the payoff function by solving a maximum
likelihood problem
what do we do when we write a likelihood
function what we do is that we say okay
if i observe the outcome 1 1
that means that epsilon
has to have taken uh realization in a
certain
uh
in a certain subset of r2 here
okay but the problem is that because of
the multiplicity of equilibria when i
observe one one i don't know whether
epsilon has realized here or whether
epsilon is realized here
and i'm observing the outcome of the
totally mixed equilibrium
okay
so i could say okay
well
i'm going to say that it could have come
from both
either the gray region or the red region
and that's what's what's going to be the
probability of uh of uh observing 1 1 is
going to be the sum of the gray region
and the red region and that's going to
be the piece which goes into likelihood
for that
the problem is that the same is true
when you think about 0 0 the probability
of observing 0 0
can come from the event where you
observe zero zero comes both from the
event where
epsilon realizes in the green region but
also can come from the event where
epsilon realizes in the red region
and uh totally mixed equilibrium which
peak zero zero occurs so now you could
say well
if you were to think i'm also going to
apply
this entire region to the model implied
probability of zero zero now you would
already already see that you will have a
problem because you will have a
likelihood that does not integrate to
one
and that is why you need the selection
mechanism because you need the way to
sort of cut the pie where the pie here
is the red region between a piece which
goes to 0 0 a piece which goes to one
one piece that goes to zero with one and
the p switch goes to zero to the other
one i forgot which one i had not listed
yet
okay
so
let's think in a more systematic way
what is the relationship for a fixed
selection mechanism r and the fixed
parameter vector theta
how can i figure out what the model
predicts as
the probability of the various outcomes
of the game
so
for example if you look at the
probability that the model assigns to 1
1 as outcome of the game that
probability
is going to be the probability that the
model assigns to the gray area which
here i'm calling f of grey because f is
the joint distribution of the epsilons
and and here i'm just trying to
use a shorthand to indicate
that epsilon is realized above this
level
and epsilon 2 has realized above this
level and epsilon 1 is realized above
this level giving us this gray region
but then there is going to be another
possible place from which the outcome
one one can come
which is going to be
the event where epsilon has realized in
the red region
the selection mechanism selects the
totally mixed equilibrium and the
totally mixed equilibrium happens to
give us a 1 1.
and so i need to take
this
product of probabilities here and then i
need to integrate it against the
distribution of epsilon over the right
area okay
similarly i can say well now what's the
probability according to the model that
the outcome zero one will occur
well it's going to be
the probability that epsilon realizes in
the yellow region
so this part up here
where
0 1 is the unique equilibrium of the
game
plus
i don't need to worry about the region
of multiplicity and in the region of
multiplicity 0 1 could come out in two
ways
it could be because the total mixed
equilibrium has been selected and 0 1
happens to be
the outcome of the of the game in that
case
or
the
degenerate equilibrium that assigns
probability 1 to 0 1 is selected in
which case
that's the only probability that i need
to put here and then i need to integrate
it out with respect to the distribution
of epsilon
now the reason why
point identification will fail here is
because i can find multiple values of
theta and multiple ways to divide the
region of multiplicity through the
selection mechanism r
so that when i plug this selection
mechanism r into the model and i plug
this value of t into the model
i'm going to exactly match the
distribution of outcomes of the game
that i see in the data
okay
so i'm going to exactly find myself in a
situation where i can take two different
values of theta
plug them into the model
use two different criteria to complete
the model
and still match the distribution of the
data
okay
questions
okay
so one clarification question uh because
i don't remember all the notation
so sigma once in the mixed region sigma
the mixed equilibrium does it depend on
the thetas and the epsilons of the x's
like it does
it depends on
it depends on uh so if
sigma one star
would be
oh let me see my own notation for a
second
yeah
it's going to be i think minus x 2 beta
2
minus delta 2
over epsilon 2
and this is the other one is going to be
the opposite way
because it has to be the one that makes
him different between the two actions
right so it will the short of it whether
i wrote correctly the the expression
here or not uh i think i did but the
short maybe the yeah
uh
the short of it is that yes it depends
on all the parameters and it depends on
the epsilon
and that's part of what makes it more
difficult than in the case of pure
strategy but i'll get back to that
when i when i go through simplifications
so i guess then i mean uh
so i guess the integrals that are there
are to take as input delta as well or uh
uh
so and then like kind of like i mean
okay so maybe the notation so
so so the notation is implicit because
these expressions for the sigma one star
and sigma to start they get too big to
put on the slide
but that's right so the
let me perhaps instead of focusing on
the specific uh
expression here which i may also have
gotten wrong let me just say that this
is sigma 1
star is a function of the entire x
vector
and the antarctica vector oh and the
epsilon
actually let me write it like this
so this is a more compact way and also
probably less
written to me we put the typo there yes
other questions
so one thing that i want to emphasize
here
is that conceptually
you could define this sharp
identification region so what you could
ask yourself okay i understand this idea
that there are different ways in which i
can cut this region of multiplicity
and as i consider all the possible
conceivable ways
to cut the region of multiplicity
i'm going to collect all the values of
theta
which are associated with a specific cut
because once you decide how to cut the
region of multiplicity
you can
you have a well-defined likelihood
function so you could literally imagine
that you're going to take a selection
mechanism
first selection mechanism and you're
going to write the likelihood function
associated with the selection mechanism
maximize the likelihood obtain theta and
then you're going to do it again for a
different selection mechanism and then
again for a different selection
mechanism and so on and so forth and by
doing that for all the possible
selection mechanisms which are
completely unrestricted probability
distributions that only need to satisfy
these two conditions
if you could do that
that would give you
the sharp identification region what
does that mean that every parameter
theta in that region so every parameter
for which you can find a selection
mechanism
such that this condition here is
satisfied
is a parameter that is consistent with
the observed date and maintained
assumptions so it's parameter that is
consistent with the data generating
process and the data that you see
and so
collecting all those values exhausts the
information in the data and in the
assumptions and that's what you really
want to obtain
however in practice this probability
distribution this selection mechanism is
a nasty object to work with
because
we call it an infinite dimensional
nuisance parameter because it depends on
x and epsilon and we don't have and can
depend on theta we don't have any
uh
we don't want to
take a stand on what this selection
mechanism is and if we don't take a
stand on what the selection mechanism is
um
it becomes an object that you know even
in a statistical or in computational
sense it's hard to work with and part of
what i want to show you today actually
the main thing that i want to show you
today is that there are tools in the
toolkit provided by mathematics that
basically allows us to not have to worry
about this selection mechanism at all so
to bypass it so that we don't need to
compute to do a computations related to
it
but before i go there i want to show you
an example
of you could say well okay
there is going there are different
possible selection mechanisms
but surely there are more reasonable
selection mechanisms than others
so
if i were to restrict myself to the
reasonable selection mechanism would it
actually matter which one i pick at the
end of the day
so what i want to show you is a table
from a paper in econometrica by steve
berry 1992 paper so paper that was
written when there was no not no work on
this idea of partial identification
people were going for complete models
and what he was studying was the entry
in the airline industry so he wanted to
understand the competition between delta
and united and so on all the airlines
there were many more airlines in the in
the united states in 1992
and um
um so
he
i'm not going to get into the details of
that paper but one of the things he did
is that he he one of the things he did
was to look at maximum likelihood
estimates
when under two distinct selection
mechanisms one was that the most
profitable firm moves first
and the other one was that the incumbent
moves first and one could argue that
both are very reasonable selection
mechanism
and on some parameters um
like for example the
this one here it didn't make too much of
a difference which selection mechanism
you picked but for example on a
parameter such that such as the distance
between
uh
the cities
covered by the airline so the city pair
that constitutes a market so whether you
enter in that market or not
in this case we see that the sign on the
parameter flips
and these are statistically so in
parenthesis here you have the standard
error so these are statistically
significantly different uh
um
estimates the effect of the popular of
population size and whether fermenters
are not the market has a size which is
like three and a half times as large and
the other for another thing which is
interesting here is that the correlation
parameter takes a dramatically different
value in the two cases
and so what i'm trying to convey to you
by showing you this table which was
based on estimates in unsuspecting time
when nobody thought about partial
identification is that it actually can
make a lot of difference
which selection mechanism you use and
these are two selection mechanisms which
are arguably both very closely
okay
so
let me tell you with this long
introduction let me tell you what we
actually do to deal with this problem
so the our key idea is to avoid all
together to use to to work with this
infinite dimensional nuisance parameter
which is the selection mechanism
and we do that by leveraging the theory
of random sets
the idea here is actually intuitively
very simple the idea is the following
the model predicts a set
a set of outcomes
there is a lot of work in mathematics
that give us probability distribution
notion of expected value and so on for
sets
so why don't we go and use the tools for
what our model predicts
and hopefully by doing so we can use do
standard econometrics in a way that is
easier that was the idea
and so
um i'm going to jump directly here to my
definition of a random closed set just
to because this the reason why i want to
show you the formal definition is just
because it's going to feed back to the
idea of which kind of solution concepts
can i allow for
we have that you know starting so we are
going to define all our random variables
on some probability space
omega fracture f and t which i'm going
to take to be non-atomic just because it
simplifies things and usually in
economics we always have some underlying
random variable that has a continuous
distribution so the the probability
space is non-atomic
um
and i'm going to denote by calligraphic
f the collection of closed subsets of rd
and i'm going to say that the map
bold x bold capital x here is a random
closed set
if for every set k
the pre-image of this set k
belongs to the sigma algebra so
what's the pre-image of the set k
is going to be
the
elements of the
sample space
such that
um
the realization of the set capital x
associated with this element of the
sample space
intersected with intersected with this
uh
set k is not empty
so let's try to step back from this
abstract uh definition when we have a
random variable we have that random
variable associates with which element
of the of the sample space
um
an element of r or rd if it's a random
vector and the pre image of that random
variable has to belong to the sigma
algebra for for for the
for that to be a random variable so for
it to be measurable and here there is
just a different
notion of pre-image which is basically
based on tracing out which the events of
which elements the set x hits
and if you uh and by looking at all the
events where the set x hits any set k
you're actually in fact going to be able
to trace out the entire distribution of
the set x
so the point is that in terms of
solution concepts what we show in the
paper but i'm not going to show formally
today is that if capital x is the set of
mixed strategy nash equilibria
then in fact it's not hard to show
actually it's easy to show that uh that
set of mixed strategy that set of mixed
strateginess equilibria satisfies this
measurability condition
and so if you want to use a different
solution concept like your strategy nash
equilibrium or
by agent correlated equilibrium or
by asian nash equilibrium rationality of
level k whichever
you what one needs to do is to verify
that this condition is satisfied so that
you have measurability if that's the
case then you can apply the the set of
tools that i'm going to show you next
so once you have a random set
uh
the idea one key role is going to be
played by the selections of the random
clause set
so one of the people who contributed a
lot to this literature was boba is bob
bauman and the way that uh
he always he describes random sets is
that you can think of random sets as a
bundle of random variables
and so
this the selections are the bundle of
are the random variables that belong to
this bundle okay so we say that
lowercase x is a
selection of uh
capital x
if lowercase x belongs to capital x with
probability 1.
and so here is just a simple graphical
depiction of what
a random set x could be where this
random set x actually is an interval
right and this interval just takes
different realizations across different
elements of the sample space and little
x has to be a random variable that lies
inside this interval with probability
and so
as i look at the interval across values
of omega i get this tube this irregular
tube that i plotted here
now an important remark for later is
that
in fact each each selection of the
random sat can be built using that using
a possible selection mechanism from the
notation that i showed you before this
capital r this probability distribution
could in fact be used to give you a rule
to pick
this little x here
okay
questions
okay
so then what i want to do is now well
now that i've defined the random set and
its selections i actually want to define
the expected value of random set
and and the reason is because defining
this expected value of the random set
will allow me to leverage many results
that then i will go back to my
identification problem and close the
circle for how it is related okay
so i'm going to say that this random set
x is integrable if it possesses at least
one integrable selection
and i'm going to say that it's
integrably bounded if all its selections
are integrable
and just to keep it in mind if we think
about the set of mixed strategy nash
equilibria that set of mixed strategy
nash equilibria the elements of that sat
are a subset of the of the unit square
and therefore all the selections of the
set of next strategy nash equilibrium
are going to be integrable okay
and so then i can define the notion of
expectation for a random clause set to
be what
again so this is called the almond or
selection expectation and the idea is
that a random sac is a bundle of random
variables
you pick out of this
of this box of random variables the ones
which are integrable
you compute their standard expectation
and you put them in a new basket that
you're going to call the omen
expectation that's literally what's
going on here
okay
the result that is going to be useful
for our identification analysis is the
following
if you have a set x random close set x
which is integrable
and is defined on a non-atomic
probability space
then
the almond expectation of this set is
going to be a closed convex set
expectation of that set is going to be
equal to the omni expectation of the
convex cell of that set and what's
really important for what i'm going to
show you next
is this last property
that the support function
of this almond expectation in direction
u
is actually equal to the standard
expected value of the support function
of the set x
this ability to pass the alma
expectation
inside
sorry to take it outside of the set and
put it out here
is what's going to give us all the
computational tractability
so again the result is the following
that
if you take
you the support function
of beyond expectation
is equal to the expected value of the
support function of the set
and i'll come back to this result when i
in the next slide that i connected to
our identification problem
so that i will be able to tell you why
this result is so useful but for now i'm
just going to ask you to keep it in mind
that this this result here will come
back
okay
so
i've finished my little detour on a
random set theory
so
natural question is
okay how does that help me with the
identification problem that that was
described before
here is how it's all gonna work
do the following for the experiment fix
the value of calligraphic theta and fix
the value of x and epsilon
and now consider so take a selection
from the set of mixed strategy nash
equilibrium so take a specific
equilibrium
now that specific equilibrium is going
to imply
a probability distribution of reaction
profiles right
so
0 0 is going to occur with probability 1
minus sigma 1 times 1 sigma 2 1 0 with
probability sigma 1 times 1 sigma 2 etc
now
collect all these distributions for all
values of for all the selections of s
theta into a new set which i'm going to
call capital w
theta which itself again is going to be
a function of x and epsilon where this
capital w of sigma is going to be given
by all these vectors
across the possible values of sigma in
the set of mixed strategy nash
equilibrium
okay
as i mentioned before it's easy to show
that these sets as theta and w theta
satisfy the measurability condition that
defines a random closure
now before moving on let's reflect for a
moment
what is the set capital w
theta the set capital w theta actually
collects all model implied conditional
distributions
for the
outcomes of the game given x and epsilon
so if you fix the value of x and epsilon
you condition on the value of x and
epsilon
then you ask yourself what are the
possible probability distributions of y
implied by this model well you know that
once you fix x and epsilon
the only randomness left
is associated with the with the mixing
okay
and so
the probability that
zero zero we realize is one minus sigma
one times one minus sigma two
and so on so forth
but the model does not have give you a
single sigma one sigma two pair that is
a mixed strategy equilibrium the model
gives you multiple
in our case it gives you at most free
right in the simple example that we're
considering so far so we have three of
those
okay
those are the first apparent ones but
then we also have to remember that there
are all the possible mixtures of this
free equilibrium right because at the
end of the day we can mix across them
and so in this set w calligraphic
w theta we are going to collect not only
the
conditional distributions of y given x
and epsilon associated with the
three mixed strategy equilibria that i
put in the picture before but also older
mixtures
okay
now
this is a conditional distribution given
up
conditioning on both and x and epsilon
but of course when we do statistical
inference we need to get rid of the
unobservables right we always average
out the unobservable
and that's where the amount expectation
comes in to play an important role
because now what we're going to do is
we're going to take the conditional
allowance expectation of this set w
theta
by basically taking
all the selections of the set as theta
and then computing the conditional
expectation of the
vector little w associated with that
selection sigma conditional on x
now this set
this condition allows an expectation is
a set that exists and is unique this was
not proven by us but it's one of the
results in a random set theory
but what is
shown by us is that this set here is the
set of all model implied conditional
distributions of y given x
again there is a strong connection with
the idea of selection mechanism that i
spoke to you about before
because what one can show
is that this almond expectation in fact
collects
all
the probability distributions
as i have shown
in this as derived for example here
it's going to collect all these type of
vectors of this form
across all possible selection mechanisms
are where again the selection mechanisms
can depend on x epsilon and theta okay
that's what it's going to do this almond
expectation collects all such vectors
and now you could ask
now you could ask well
how does that help me why does it help
me to think in terms of this set
if you're going to bring me back
to
talk to me about the selection mechanism
that you be said is hard to work with
the reason why it's helpful is because
to compute the actual allowance
expectation i would need to work with
the selection mechanism but to compute
the support function of the set w theta
i don't need to do that
because the support function of the set
w theta is simply the support function
of a free element set in my example
the set w theta includes uh the
probability distributions associated
with at most free equilibria
the two total the two degenerate ones
and the total mixed equilibrium
so we're going to compute the support
function of these three-point set and
then we're going to integrate out
epsilon by taking the expected value
and so computing the support function of
the amount expectation is actually very
easy
while computing the almond expectation
itself up here would be very difficult
because it would require me to go
through the use of the selection
mechanism
okay
questions
okay
so now to close the loop of how do i
characterize this sharp identification
region theta i
i'm going to denote by as a shorthand
p 0 y given x
the
vector in the simple case the four by
one vector
of the probability of each of the
possible outcomes of the game in this in
this case
and now if the model is correctly
specified meaning players playing
strategy nash equilibrium and my utility
the payoff functions are correctly
specified and so on and the true value
of theta that generated the data it has
to be that the distribution of the
outcomes of the game that i see in the
data
belongs to this almond expectation why
because the omen expectation
collects all the probability
distributions over outcomes of the gain
implied by the model and if the game if
the model is correctly specified the
distribution of outcomes that are
observing the data has to be an element
of the is an element of this common
expectation
and so then
to define my identification region i
simply need to check
what are what is going to be the set of
values of theta that are observationally
equivalent it's going to be the ones for
which
i cannot separate this convex set
from this point
and that problem is a problem that is
easy to solve through complex
optimization because it's basically just
a separating hyperplane problem
and so what's going to be the set of
parameters theta that are observational
equivalent they're going to be the ones
such that the support function
of this singleton p 0 y given x
is dominated by the support function of
the oven expectation which as i
mentioned before is just equal to the
expected value of the support function
of the set w theta
and so trying to summarize this in
pictures in terms of what is entailed
here to do
the idea is going to be that
i'm going to
first obtain the set of mixed strategy
nash equilibrium
each element of the set of mixed
strategy nash equilibria is going to
imply a probability distribution
over outcome profiles for this game
and i'm going to take this set w theta
which as you can see here just contains
three elements and i'm going to compute
the support function of this set
and now the support function of this set
in the regions of uniqueness is just
going to if you compare this set w theta
now what you do is you're just going to
say what's the maximum
over w
in w theta
of u
transpose w
right
so in this uh in this region of
uniqueness here
that inner product is just going to for
example pick out
the fourth element of the vector u and
that's what i get here
and in the region of multiplicity i'm
taking the maximum between the inner
product of the direction vector u with
three elements and so it's going to be
the maximum between u2 u3
and the product with the total mixed
equilibrium
so this is just a nonlinear function of
epsilon which then i'm going to
integrate out with respect to the
distribution of epsilon
and
the
[Music]
support function so the
the support function here is
the resulting problem here
is going to be concave
and so i can solve this problem through
a convex optimization
questions
okay so
um as i mentioned before the approach
that i just
explained can be applied to
many different solution concepts
correlated equilibrium based correlated
equilibrium rationality of level care
just a few examples
as i said presumably any other solution
concept subject to the requirement
that
the set of equilibria which is implied
has to satisfy the measurability
condition that i showed you before
computationally
what's
what what's to do here
is the part about verification of
whether candidate calligraphic theta
belongs to theta i i think that that
problem we have solved satisfactorily
because we can just
solve that problem for convex
optimization
uh in fact in certain cases it's just
going to be a linear program
however
tracing out the entire set beta i can be
quite hard because there is no
reason to believe
in general that the set theta is
convex
so sometimes the set guitar looks
something like this
and so
tracing it out in an efficient way
something that we don't know enough
about
how to do it
was that a question
okay
is it easy to do the convex hull of the
identified set easily or not even other
than
that so that is something that i so
okay
excellent question um
two parts there are uh i thought a
little bit about that specific question
so something that we did do is that for
example sometimes in in practical
applications we
don't necessarily care about
the entire set but we care about its
projections because for example you want
to know whether
um
imagine that i had drawn this picture
these lines well so that they were
actually the projections maybe what you
care about is simply whether um
[Music]
the
interaction effects are within us
you you care for example only about the
interaction effects and so you just want
to have an interval of values for the
effect of firm one and therm two and
vice versa for the other
and so there what
what i've tried in my own work is to use
uh
variation method based bayesian
optimization methods to solve this
non-convex optimization problem
the other thing i thought of doing was
convexifying
the moment inequalities that result here
so if you look at this expression here
these are what we would call
moment inequalities because this could
be written
analogously as u transpose p 0
minus this almond expectation
i'm just gonna write it like this
less or equal than zero so what i
thought that might be one could try to
do was to convexify
this uh
[Music]
sorry convexify this as a function of
theta
and then
uh so i think that like if you convexify
this you would get the convex cell of
the set
but but then i thought that the
convexification exercise itself is
computationally very costly so my
concern was that i'm just moving the
place where where there is the
bottleneck
if that's what you had in mind
here
okay because i mean
yeah
sorry
yeah
so another question is so there is
dimensionality in the
theta vector like uh
anyways the the coefficient vector
there's also like this example here
talks about two firms
so i was wondering like
your convex optimization approach like
if i have
you know
you know k firms right so like
is there an exponential explosion like
because like you know now the outcomes
are like two to the two to the k
possible outcomes
are you gonna are you gonna pay for that
in the algorithm
the two to the k
so
um
so my the
the convex optimization problem has
stood 2 decay variables because the size
of the
u vector is the same as the size of the
outcome space
what is my concern my bigger concern is
that
[Music]
computing the set of equilibria
becomes increasingly hard
if i have
more firms for example
so i viewed that as a separate problem
i view that as
so if i were for example to
stick with pure strategy nash
equilibrium then i know that in fact my
convex optimization problem boils down
to linear programming problem
and so in that case i'm not really too
worried i'm not terribly worried about
the dimension of the u set or the number
of constraints you can though the number
of constraints is going to grow
uh quickly but because it's a linear
program i think it's okay
again i'm not a computer scientist so
maybe i'm missing so my thinking that
it's okay is
misguided
but what i think is more problematic is
that the more firms i have the harder is
i think it seems to me that the first
bottleneck is how do i compute all the
set of equilibrium
because an additional advantage of this
toy example that i showed you is that in
fact i know exactly what's the nash
correspondence whether it's in mixed
strategies or in pure strategies but in
more complex games what the economists
do is that we simulate the game which
i'm also not sure if it's the best thing
that one can do
yeah i mean i mean there's a i guess an
array of questions that one can pose for
example you know like
maybe you have like kk
firms but you know like in your
observational data
you see up to five of them participating
at any time
and like now do you have to pay these
two to the cave and though you only see
i don't know cages five at most or
whatever like you know like there's i
guess
and uh a a set of questions to ask but
yeah i mean i guess it's open-ended so
i'm just curious what your thoughts
overall but
we can take it offline as well yeah yeah
so my concern with what you are just
saying is that if it's literally only
five firms are playing i've uh
or are in my data i have a different
problem which is that that setup that
you just proposed calls into question my
assumption that
from the data i can learn the joint
distribution of y and x right
because it's not clear that i can really
learn the distribution of y
of the entire vector y of k
uh you know the action of the
distribution of actions of k firms or
the distribution outcomes of k firms
if only some of them actually play
right
so that's an additional concern
which which in some sense is separate
from this identification question
okay yes thank you yeah
yeah thanks
so
um i think i have like zero minutes is
that the accurate statement
yes
okay
then uh i would like to skip the
simplification for pure strategies let
me just tell you my uh main takeaways in
the summary
so my the main takeaway here is the
following models with strategic behavior
often deliver these such valued
predictions that is true for
finite games it's true for
auctions it's true for networks and
network formation problems
and the presence of these set valued
predictions creates difficulties for
point identification intuitively the
reason is because you can find these
multiple pairs of selection mechanisms
and model parameters that are going to
deliver the same distribution of the
observed variables
while selection mechanisms are a
perfectly fine way to think about the
problem and to conceptualize it in your
mind they create practical issues
because they're infinite-dimensional
nuisance parameters and so if possible
it's better to avoid them and our
proposal here is to use these tools from
random set theory as a natural toolkit
because they give us this
expectations for all the selections of
the model predictions that then we can
connect to the support function
uh i skip the part about pure strategies
only but there are also nice
simplifications related to
characterizations of the distributions
of all the selections of model
predictions again through simple
inequalities
and so
the reason why this is helpful is
because it allows us to determine if a
specific calligraphic theta belongs to
the eye through a convex program that
sometimes is even linear but as i
mentioned one of the big open questions
is that i can easily determine whether a
specific calligraphic theta belongs to
theta i but then because theta i is not
convex
i i i do face a problem after that which
is how do i
efficiently characterize the entire
theta i
and even if i care only about
projections of theta i
what's the best way to compute these
projections we have a paper that
provides a way to do that
but we are econometricians who are not
uh people who do
you know
there are people who know how to do this
better than us and i would certainly be
very interested to to to get ideas and
suggestions about this
thank you
any questions
we have some questions already
maybe actually i have it
yeah
all right so uh i have a question so in
all your uh your examples
uh everyone you have this assumption of
the atomless distribution
uh which i guess it's it's natural in in
many economic contexts
uh how important this assumption what if
i have something that's more like
discrete which is more closer to a
computer science kind of
uh way of thinking uh
do these results carry over or partially
or which
the problem is that if you have a
um
if you have
uh atomic structure
then the atomicity structure is going to
have an impact on what the expectation
looks like
that's that's the main idea so let me
try to keep it simple and if not i can
add a page here and scribble something
it's a little bit like with random
variables so
in the random variables were discrete
random variables and continuous random
variables so if the atomicity is here if
if we have atomicity then the omen
expectation is going to end up being
like
[Music]
the expected value of discrete random
variable so it's literally going to be
um
the you know probability of the
of the realization imagine that you have
a sample space which has uh three atoms
so that is going to be
uh
the realization of the random set
associated with the first atom
multiplied by the probability of that
atom plus the second plus the third so
now what's going to be lost is the
convexity result
so and
and and the loss of the convexity result
is going to
um
so then the results that i've showed you
would apply to the convex hull
of the of the set of equilibrium
without without the atomicity
the convex hull of the the expected the
other expectation of the convex cell of
the set of equilibria equals the only
expectation of the free equilibria
but without the
uh but with atomicity
it's it's literally like you know it's a
superset of it does that answer your
question
i guess yes
[Music]
so in the case where
my set of uh so can i sorry can i can i
add the small point yes uh so what does
it imply what it implies is that
something that we really care about or
we cared about at the time of thinking
about this work
was to
uh come up with a methodology so that we
would get this sharp identification
region so the sharpness was really
important to us that all the details
that we give you for this
characterization are thetas that are
consistent with the data and the
assumptions
now if i work with the
if the convex sul
of the of the set of equilibria the
expected value of the convex cell is not
equal to the expected value of the state
of equilibrium itself which happens in
the case of atomicity
then the set of parameter values that
i'm going to give you is a superset of
the sharp identification region which
means that i'm leaving information on
the table
so i'm not using all the information in
the data in the model i'm giving you too
many parameter values based on the data
and the model i could figure out that
there are less parameter values
thank you
did that make sense yes that makes sense
actually thank you very much okay good
uh any any last questions from the
audience
okay if not we're going to thank
francesca again thank you very much for
your time
thank you